you have to get in through 12 feet of
concrete and 70,000 gallons of
pressurized water without any metal no
oxygen tanks Benji stand by to receive
Ethan you ready important point if you
haven't open that hatch after two and a
half minutes we're both dead no no no
did you get aboard whoa whoa you okay to
drive me a minute ago you were dead what
are you talking about this is not gonna
win well
mr. chairman the time has come to
dissolve the IMF it's not just a rogue
organization
it is a disgraced one
shutting down the IMF as a mistake you
may regret
nope The Syndicate is real do they know
who you are rogue nation trained to do
it we do an aunty IMF
they're coming after us with everything
they've got
oh boy you want to bring down the
syndicate it's impossible your position
I have I sure is about to start get it
you and your king will answer for every
want and act of mayhem you are
responsible for now we are all wanted by
the CIA awesome
this may be our last mission
let's make a count
come on yeah
dental right now oh my god
you
you